فقدت اسهم بعد شركات التكنولوجيا اكثر من
50 بالمئه من قيمتها السوقيه خلال الفتره
الماضيه بينما اعلنت عن تسريح نسب كبيره
من موظفيها ولا يبدو ان ايام هذه الشركات
افلتت من الازمه الراهنه واليكم الارقام
700 مليار دولار مخسرتهم مايكروسوفت من
قيمتها السوقيه اما متى فغسلت اكثر من 600
مليار دولار هذا العام اي ما يعادل 70% من
قيمتها تقريبا ريفيان شركه السيارات
الكهربائيه انخفضت اسومها باكثر من 80%
بعد ان بلغ سقها اكثر من 150 مليار دولار
امازون بدورها خسرت ريليون دولار من
قيمتها السوقيه لتصبح اول شركه تخسر هذا
الكم من القيمه السوقيه كما تراجعها صندوق
رنا سينس للطرح العام الاولاني وهو سلم من
الشركات الامريكيه المدرجه الحديثه لنسبه
57% خلال العام الماضي